a leader of Thailand's rescue mission to
save 12 boys and their soccer coach from
a cave now says we have a limited amount
of time he spoke after a former Thai
Navy SEAL 38 year old Salman Coonan died
inside the cave complex from a lack of
oxygen officials say he was working as a
volunteer diver and was delivering
oxygen canisters to the scene when he
collapsed the soccer team has now been
trapped for 15 days more heavy rain is
on the way and that could bring new
flooding inside the cave and Tracey is
at the scene in Shanghai where there's
new urgency in the rescue effort then
good morning yeah good morning so the
death of this diver certainly has raised
questions about whether or not these
young untrained boys could survive that
same kind of dangerous journey out of
this cave however the head of the Thai
Navy SEALs says that they're gonna
continue their mission until all 12 and
their coach get out and as you mentioned
those heavy rains that are headed this
way certainly added urgency because time
is running out crews are working
frantically to pump out water from
inside the cave system where 12 boys in
their 25 year old soccer coach are
trapped with monsoon rains in the
forecast this weekend floodwaters are
expected to once again rise but that's
not the only concern authorities say
oxygen levels inside the cave are
dropping and they are rushing to install
a three mile long oxygen tube we
originally thought the boys could stay
safe inside the cave for quite some time
this Thai seal commander said but
circumstances have changed we have a
limited amount of time from the cave
entrance to an area known as chamber 3
the water is now down to around
knee-high level but the space between
chamber 3 and the boys is still
completely flooded the only way through
it includes a nearly 100 foot underwater
dive that is close to where the former
Navy SEAL diver died on Thursday Thai
authorities say he was on his way back
from delivering air tanks to the group
when he passed out underwater he was
pulled out unconscious and unable to be
revived authorities are trying to get
the floodwaters to a level where the
boys would not have to dive and could
swim out with life jackets on
and their heads above water so just over
here is the entrance to the cave and all
day long they are bringing things in and
out right now it appears they're
actually trying to move in these large
submersible water pumps in order to pump
more water out of the flooded cavern but
even if they are successful in pumping
enough water out there is worried the
group does not have the endurance to
make the nearly five hour long trip out
of the cave
some are showing signs of weakness and
malnutrition and most do not know how to
swim vomiting I'm worried he has never
dived said the father of one of the boys
but he can swim a little they are
quickly running out of options here so
crews are still looking for other
entrances to the cave including from
above and they've talked about even
potentially drilling a hole through the
mountain to try to reach the trap boys
Alex then Tracy and Thailand thinks bent
that story every day every chapter of it
is gut-wrenching it is so difficult to
watch I mean I don't think we can
overstate how much everybody in the
world is watching and rooting for these
children difficult for us imagine your
parents are going if you had any doubts
about how dangerous this is one less of
that diver tells ya thoughts and prayers